das Thema Wohnungsnot Wohnungsbau ist ja
eins der wirklich gravierendsten und
wichtigsten Themen die auch jetzt die
aktuelle Regierung natürlich sehr
beschäftigt und meiner Meinung nach
bitte immer noch viel zu wenig kreativ
viel zu wenig innovativ gedacht die
Chance insbesondere für Ballungszentren
wie auch hier in Berlin ist das Thema
Hochhausbau man kann eben wenn man in
die Höhe baut sehr viel mehr in Multimix
Gebäuden unterbringen man kann
nachhaltige Gebäude bauen Windkraft
Betrieben mit Solarenergie und diese
Chance wird viel zu wenig genutzt obwohl
sehr viele tolle Beispiele auch im
Ausland schon gibt und da fehlt einfach
der Mut die Kreativität und ähm ja ein
bisschen so dass ja der Mut einfach das
zu machen in Deutschland gibt es ein
Beispiel im Ausland was sie besonders
bewundern oder wo sie sagen dieses
Beispiel würde ich gerne auch in
Deutschland sehen es gibt mehrere
Beispiele es gibt in Wien z.B ein Holz
Hochhaus das nennt sich hoch hoch dass
das ist rein in den Holzbauweise
entstanden es gibt in Mailand ein
komplett begrühmtes hochhausgebäude sind
1500 Bäume drauf Sträucher begrünte
Dachflächen also es gibt schon solche
Dinge es gibt in Skandinavien ganz viele
Beispiele also es gibt wirklich viele
schöne Sachen die man hier auch umsetzen
könnte und die auch tatsächlich
Konfliktpotential herausnehmen würde
wenn man zum Beispiel das Tempelhofer
Feld was ja hier in Berlin immer groß
und breit diskutiert wird nämlich flach
und mit großen Flächen bebaut sondern
ihm am Rand mit nachhaltigen Hochhäusern
die auch gut aussehen die kreativ
gestaltet sind kann man eigentlich sehr
viel gewinnen nachhaltige Hochhäuser wie
ist das für Stadtbild für Stadtbild kann
das sehr positiv sein natürlich wollen
wir jetzt hier kein neues Märkisches
Viertel bauen keine trabantenstätte wie
sie in den 60er 70er Jahren gebaut
wurden sondern wirklich das Bauen hat
sich auch weiterentwickelt ne das äh das
kann also sehr viel grüner sein das kann
sehr viel natürlicher wenn man eben
Baustoff Holz sie natürlich
nachwachsenden
eigentlich sehr positiv sein wenn man
auch ein bisschen schaut dass es nicht
zu einheitlich ist dass man in die
Höhlen variiert dass man auch natürlich
schaut wo ist jetzt ein 60 Meter Haus in
wo passt ein 150 Meter aus dem Mann soll
jetzt keine riesen Türme in bestehende
altbaufviertel reinbauen das ist klar
also ich habe aufmerksam zugehört weil
es um das temporär Feld ging das ist
nämlich mein Wahlkreis und in der Tat
ich wäre auch dafür dass wir mit Blick
ins auf die Wohnungsnot die wir ja nicht
nur in Berlin sondern ganz vielen großen
Städten Ballungsgebieten haben wir
müssen einfach Vorankommen die Ampel
hatte sich ja ursprünglich im
Koalitionsvertrag des zielgesetz 400.000
Wohnungen jedes Jahr zu bauen also 1,6
Millionen in dieser Legislaturperiode
davon sind wir meilenweit entfernt für
manche Dinge das muss man auch ganz klar
sagen kann die Ampel nicht ja also den
Ukraine konnte niemand vorhersehen dass
dort Lieferketten gebrochen sind die
Bautzen entsprechend hochgehen dafür
kann sie nichts aber sie macht eben ihre
eigenen Hausaufgaben eben auch nicht ähm
wenn man sieht wie die Baugenehmigung
zahlen jetzt runter gehen wir im Januar
ähm jetzt zahlen gehabt da sind die um
25% gegenüber dem vorher eingebrochen 25
%. das heißt wir werden wahrscheinlich
in diesem Jahr statt 400.000 maximal 250
haben in den Nachfolge ja noch weniger
und deswegen glaube ich müssen wir
entschlossen gegensteuern und das das
Bündnis bezahlbares Wohnen das hatte die
bauministerin auf den Weg gebracht die
haben viele Monate getagt und haben dann
auf 67 Seiten 180 Vorschläge
zusammengetragen aber auch mir fehlt
Herr lefner da ein bisschen der Mut es
wird die Radikalität wenn wir nicht zu
einer wirklich radikalen Entschlackung
des bauordnungsrechtes kommen und die
vielen vielen Tausenden von Vorschriften
die man beim Bauen beachten muss mal
zurücknehmen dann wird bauen vor allem
extrem teuer bleiben und damit am Ende
des wohnen ja auch so teuer bleiben und
dass er das zweite der zweite Punkt wir
müssen ja auch über die Bezahlbarkeit
des Wohnens von mieten nachdenken gerade
hier in Berlin und deswegen müssen wir
da wirklich sehr stark Vorankommen da
würde ich gerne einmal einhaken und Herr
Löffler fragen wie teuer das denn ist
oder wie viel teurer ist denn so ein
grünes Haus im Gegensatz sagen wir mal
zu einem normalen nicht grünen Haus ist
es ist nicht teurer das zu bauen das ist
es ist das es ist grundsätzlich ist
alles teurer geworden auch das ist
teurer geworden natürlich und die
innovativen Energien oder Energiequellen
oder einzubauen ist natürlich das kostet
sein Geld aber es ist richtig wir müssen
trotzdem Wege finden es gibt modulares
bauen sowohl für Holz sowohl für
klassische Bauweisen und das muss eben
viel mehr gemacht werden das kann auch
trotzdem gut aussehen aber das ist als
eigentlich auch nicht die Erfindung des
Rades noch mal neu das ist eigentlich
nichts Großes wie man in anderen Ländern
sieht wir müssen das einfach nur mal
probieren Überbauung von Autobahnen
Überbauung von von Schienen äh da sind
wirklich noch Wohnflächen wo man
unbedingt warum nutzen wir diese
Potenziale nicht das ist jetzt
eigentlich äh liegt auf der Hand aber
wir machen es nicht Stichwort da ist ja
pre-fabrication das ist im Grunde also
so im Grunde Fertigteile nehmen die aber
viel besser aussehen dann macht man
jetzt nicht die Platte 2.0 sondern baut
damit ist auch ökologisch und man kann
natürlich bei diesen Neubauten auch ganz
anders ökologisch bauen das ist dann
nicht so teuer wie Häuser zu sanieren
und das ist natürlich ein toller neuer
Ansatz aber gleichzeitig ist es so dass
man natürlich gucken muss wo baut man wo
baut man nicht in die Höhe zu gehen ist
ja super aber solche Sachen müssen ja
auch gemanagt werden weil wir sehen ja
oft ein Hochhäusern dass sie dann
verrotten und dergleichen beim
Tempelhofer Feld bin ich ganz anderer
Meinung als sie ich finde dieses
Tempelhof verfälscht steht für Berlin
das muss so bleiben und ich finde es
hoch erstaunlich wenn man das fühlen
will mit irgendwelchen Wohnung ich würde
gerne ich würde gerne bevor wir ins
Tempelhofer Feld der ins Detail gehen
Sarah noch Fragen die Baumeisterin hat
dir was anderes vorgeschlagen nicht die
Hochhäuser die Grünen sind sondern die
Menschen sollen dann halt aufs Land
ziehen ähm wie empfindest du diese
Lösungsvorschläge das ist gar keine
Lösung weil es keine nicht sein dass
wenn wir zum Beispiel Wohnungsnot haben
das dann Menschen gesagt wird ja zieht
wir müssen jetzt aufs Land ziehen
Entschuldigung tut mir leid und da kommt
halt wieder so eine Lösung her die wir
eigentlich schon seit Jahren hätten viel
mehr machen müssen dass man anfängt
höher zu bauen ähm mein Heimatstadt in
Frankfurt baut man ja bekanntlich so
hoch
aber ähm nee also da muss das andere
Lösung geben und vielleicht ist es ja
auch ganz normal statt soziologisch
gesehen ist Großstädte größer werden und
mehr ins Auto könnte man ja auch eine
Million Wohnungen schaffen weil eben so
warum wird das nicht gemacht ja gute
Frage das müsste man dann also
wahrscheinlich weiß er das besser weil
er kommt ja quasi auch aus Berlin und
hatte mit den Leuten zu tun die näher da
dran sind was würden Sie da sind die
berühmte Berliner draufhöhe 21 Meter wo
man lange Zeit nicht so drüber bauen
durfte das ist einer der Gründe oder nur
mit großen Ausnahmen aber wie jetzt
auch nur mit entsprechenden
Ausnahmegenehmigung aber noch mal zurück
zu diesem Vorschlag ich meine wenn ich
aufs Land ziehe im Land gibt es
natürlich solche Häuser nicht oder noch
nicht sondern gibt's die Altbauten oder
die Bauten aus den 60er Jahren oder den
Fachwerkhäuser die natürlich erheblich
saniert werden müssen also das muss man
natürlich beantworten wenn man so ein
Vorschlag macht ich wohne auf dem Land
da kommt der Bus einmal in einer Stunde
es gibt keine Ladestation oder
dergleichen also muss man sich so eine
anschaffen also dieser Vorschlag ist so
weit weg von der Realität dass ich mich
wirklich wundere darüber wie man den
ernsthaft machen kann
also wenn man mal so denkt SPD auch
wieder die Partei die eigentlich sehr
nah an den Bürger ist Volkspartei sehr
sozial also ich finde das nicht so
zahlen wenn die Menschen sagt sie
ist irgendwelche für den Vorschlag wir
wollen ja auch eine Gegenmeinung wenn
jemand dafür ist da wäre es auch gerne
sagen also nicht unbedingt dafür aber
also richtig ist natürlich dass wir
viele Probleme die wir bei
Wohnungsknappheit in den Städten haben
jetzt nicht alleine in den Städten lösen
kommen sondern in Räumen Denken und die
die Ballungsgebiete als Ganzes
betrachten also die Speck oder von
Berlin das ist schon vernünftig bessere
Infrastruktur da anzubinden dass man
eben leider Infrastruktur hat dass man
Glasfaser dort hat weil viele Menschen
wollen ja durchaus auf dem Land leben
und das finde ich ist eben der
Unterschied die machen wir das dann sagt
die Menschen zieht mal aufs Land wenn
die am Ende entscheiden ich möchte gerne
Ausland weil die Bedingungen dort so
attraktiv sind dann finde ich das total
gut und dafür muss Politik auch Sorgen
aber dieser patellalistische Politik
Ansatz den Menschen von oben sagen zu
müssen was er jetzt mal machen müsst das
ist der Kritikpunkt den man glaube ich
daran deutlich machen muss warum wollen
die Menschen eigentlich in der Stadt
leben so gerne ich denke in der Stadt
leben hat ja auch viele Vorteile man
braucht jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Auto
z.B man kann man hier sehen Berlin sehr
gut mit dem öffentlichen Nahverkehr
angebunden ich bin mitten im Leben ich
muss nicht weit zur Arbeit fahren
anderen ich muss nicht ein eigenes Haus
bauen oder ein Haus kaufen es muss dann
auch von der Stadt keine Bahn keine
Straße dahin gebaut werden die
Infrastruktur ist schon da kann genutzt
werden das können alte Industrieareale
sein das können Parkplätze sein es ist
alles schon da es muss eigentlich nur
der das Wohnhaus gebaut werden da kann
dann die Schule rein die Kita die
Sporthalle da kann können pocket-hilfe
errichtet werden und dann hat man kurze
Wege da unten ist ein Einzelhandel drin
man kann also das ist das hat so viele
Vorteile und man muss eben nicht in
Pankow äh irgendwelchecker bebauen die
dann wieder versichert sagen wir mal im
15 Meter Umkreis abspielen nein das das
tut ja sowieso nicht also ich meine die
sind ja trotzdem in der Stadt unterwegs
aber es würde natürlich wahnsinnig viel
CO2 einspannen wenn Sie nicht mit dem
Auto aus Schöneiche dann eben ins
Zentrum fahren müssen sondern wenn sie
eben da schon wohnen was für viele auch
sehr attraktiv ist aber Sie können sich
ja auch teilweise gar nicht mehr leisten
also schauen Sie eben wie kommen Sie in
die Außen Bezirke das heißt wieder ich
brauche ein Auto weil dafür der Bus halt
dann auch nicht mehr so oft wie eine
Innenstadt die BVG möchte jetzt für
keine Ahnung in den nächsten 50 Jahren
für 50 Milliarden Euro das U-Bahn-Netz
ausbauen
ja sicherlich aber wenn man in der
Großstadt wohnt muss man sich auch in
gewisser Hinsicht auch Einschränkungen
ich glaube in Berlin zumindest innerhalb
des s-rings braucht man tatsächlich
nicht zwingend ein Auto und ich glaube
es gibt hier auch tatsächlich viele
Menschen die gern darauf verzichten
darüber Berlin ist eben nicht nur
S-Bahn-Ring das ist merkt man ja auch
wenn man das letzte mal anschaut innen
drin sozusagen quasi alles grün außen um
alles schwarz da gibt's eben groß komm
selber zum Beispiel da ist man ohne
eigenes Auto ziemlich aufgeschmissen da
gibt's wieder Carsharing Angebote und
der öffentliche Personennahverkehr ist
auch nicht so besonders gut ausgebaut
und ich glaube diese Lebensrealität der
Menschen die muss man in der Politik
einfach ernst nehmen und dafür auch
einen guten Vorschlag machen und nicht
eben in seiner Blase immer nur auf
Berlin Mitte und Friedrich sein
Kreuzberg achten damit kommt man nicht
weiter nein natürlich man kommt nicht
weit aber man darf ja nicht verhehlen
also die Stadt wächst nun mal weiter und
insbesondere die Innenstadtlagen sind
ausgesprochen attraktiv und dafür muss
man einfach Angebote schaffen
Frankfurt das ist auch in München in
Hamburg auch so unter in Hamburg macht
uns ja schon sehr stark dass man hier
gebaut es ist aber auch ein Irrtum zu
glauben ist irgendwie alles besser also
wenn man jetzt mal also Land ist ja auch
zum Beispiel kleinen Stadt sage ich mal
und den kleinen Kreisstädten da hast ja
auch Wohnungsnot da wird ja auch viel
gebaut aber da ist jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie alles besser also die haben da
auch ähnliche Probleme wie man es in
größeren Städten hat wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie